tomorrow you think darkness is your ally
you merely adopted the dark I was born
in it molded by it
uh that's my impression of Bane in
2012's The Dark Knight Rises when he's
chastising Batman for using the dark to
his Advantage now my impression sucks
but there's arguably no character more
associated with movie Darkness than
Batman
with 13 on-screen appearances across
nearly 60 years Batman is one of the
longest running franchises and when you
take films from across different eras
and compress them into one big barcode
looking thing they can serve as a sort
of proxy for a story about the darkening
of movies and TV in general in the 1960s
Batman movies burst with color and
brightness but by 2022's the Batman I
mean just look at it it's a movie that
lives and breathes Darkness so much
darkness that some audience members have
complained that it's almost too dark you
can see the same pattern in the Harry
Potter films and in Game of Thrones
and the Spider-Man franchises
so yeah it's not just you complaining
movies and TV shows are getting darker
and there are a few reasons why
[Music]
check out this graph by Stephen follows
a data researcher for the film industry
he charted the top 100 grossing films in
the U.S from 2000 to 2015. and what type
of camera they were shot on this point
here it's where movies flipped from film
to digital and this shift from film to
digital is part of the reason for this
shift the biggest difference between
shooting dark scenes on film versus
digital is not knowing exactly what you
have my name is Brett jukowitz I'm a
cinematographer some of my recent work
includes Ready or Not a black phone
screen and stranger things season four
when shooting a movie on film there is
way less room for error and way more
opportunities to make mistakes for one
there are no monitors that'll show
filmmakers exactly what a shot is going
to look like before they record it there
are video Taps for film cameras but
they're really just a reference for
framing it's really not representative
of how the image will actually look it's
using a light meter and measuring the
light in the scene and trusting that
you're getting what you want if you do
shoot a dark scene on film there isn't
much room to correct it later because
the information in the darkest parts of
the image is essentially lost the
overall image just becomes grainier and
in Hollywood there's little room for
error
you really can't do a scene again just
paying for the day the location there's
really no room for going back and
redoing something if it comes out too
dark or if it's not exactly what you
want
take a look at these two shots
this one from 2002 Spider-Man was shot
on film this one from 2012's The Amazing
Spider-Man was shot on digital see how
much brighter Spider-Man and Mary Jane's
faces are with film the safest bet is to
shoot with plenty of light even if
scenes are meant to be dark shooting
digitally allows you to take more
chances with Darkness because digital
shoots usually have high quality digital
monitors the way that it allows people
to see the image as it will be when it's
finished lends itself to taking more
risks plus digital cameras are generally
more sensitive to light they do capture
more into the highlights and more into
the Shadows than a film stock can
digital cameras like the one we're using
to film this right now shooting what's
called a log format this essentially is
when the camera sensor is capturing a
really flat grayish image in order to
preserve information in the highlights
and the Shadows once you bring that
footage into a color grading software
you have tons of room to push that
footage around and instead of losing
detail in the darkest parts of the image
like you would with film you can push it
way brighter and still retain that
detail and the overall image doesn't get
super grainy either
now I know what you're thinking lots of
very successful dark scenes have been
shot on film from The Godfather to The
Dark Knight to euphoria
it's not impossible to do dark scenes on
film it's just harder and riskier
regardless of film or digital shooting
dark scenes is always a balance between
information and artistic intentions
there was an episode in Severance
there's shots in that sequence where you
really are only seeing just a sliver of
his face in this sea of darkness and
watching it I was struck by it there's
instances where you really want to focus
on one thing in the frame and using
Darkness as tool to kind of guide the
eye in that way Darkness only feels like
a problem when it feels like we're
missing out on visual information that
we think we're supposed to see It's
tricky because at the same time as you
want to create a mood and a feeling for
the audience you don't want to also get
in the way of them enjoying the show
it's a balance
filmmakers are using the best screens
the world has to offer in perfectly dark
rooms when tweaking the brightness of
the content that we're all watching so
filmmakers choose to make something look
right on the best screen and they expect
that Vision to trickle down to whatever
screen you end up watching it on later
on down the line it's impossible to know
how people are going to watch it in the
end and if you make it look good on a
low quality television then when people
are in the theater it's not going to
look right for them so yes what you're
watching is dark but it's also exactly
what the filmmaker wanted you to see
there's hope that movie darkness is
still evolving for the better add Astra
and nope were filmed using regular
cameras and infrared cameras infrared
cameras allow filmmakers to essentially
steal light from the sections of the
light spectrum that are invisible to the
human eye it also creates a black Sky
which is useful for compositing when
blending the two images together you can
produce a darkness that allows you to
appear much deeper into the dark expanse
than novel movie Darkness would